con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar de la crítica situación
del agua en monterrey méjico la segunda
ciudad más grande del país con 5.3
millones de habitantes se enfrenta
racionamientos en el suministro desde el
junio pasado siendo los barrios pobres
en su zona metropolitana los más
afectados ante toda esta problemática el
gobierno del presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador anunció que va a construir
un acueducto también que habrá pozos y
gestionará la entrega de agua por parte
de empresas que la tienen en concesión
pero muchas de estas medidas no son
inmediatas dichas acciones apuntan a
garantizar el abastecimiento en
transcurso en el transcurso de la
próxima es decir los próximos 10 años
sólo entonces a juan carlos scalesi
mayores analista y periodista juan
carlos gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 cuál es el
motivo del desabasto de agua en nuevo
léon y por qué llegó a este punto tan
crítico
hola raúl buendía pues mira el problema
no es ahora es un problema que tiene ya
varios años que se ha acentuado en los
últimos tres años y que provocó la
sequía a la que las presas que
abastecían monterrey principalmente que
la ciudad más poblada del país con más
de 5 millones de habitantes
se redujeran hasta un 2% un 7% es un
nivel de agua lo cual por composición
desabasto hay que señalar que nuevo león
particularmente monterrey tienen un 98
por ciento de cobertura casi el 99 por
ciento de cobertura de su sistema de
agua potable que el agua potable llega
por presión y que no tienen sistemas de
almacenamiento y que además el agua es
potable pero al grado de que se puede
beber del grifo la diferencia del sur
del país sin embargo pues se quedaron en
esta vez días sin agua y esto esto es un
problema que ya tiene bastante tiempo
nelson centro y se está acentuando no
solamente en nuevo león sino en todo el
norte
entonces lo que no hay es agua
distribuirla hay como pero lo que no
tenemos es agua
y de donde se puede sacar entonces esta
agua que le falta al estado de nuevo
léon y si hay una entidad del estado que
se encarga digamos para tratar de
resolver esta crisis
bueno en primer lugar hay que decir que
las una parte digamos un 37% del agua
que se extrae hacia atrás se hace a
través de pozos profundos es decir esa
agua subterránea lo demás proviene de
las presas y muchas empresas importantes
cerveceras refresqueras en la
metalúrgica por citar algunas han hecho
sus propios procesos profundos para para
garantizar su consumo y hoy les están
pidiendo que hagan una aportación lo
cual puede afectar la producción en los
compromisos comerciales de estas
empresas
y qué es lo que está pasando bueno que
no que el proyecto que había se habãa
monterrey 6 desde hace más de 10 años
era un acueducto de unos 372 kilómetros
hasta el río pánuco veracruz
pasando por otros estados de la
república pero éste provocó resistencia
como también provocó resistencia el
anuncio de otro estado de la república
donde posiblemente se podría extraer el
agua que hay que señalar que el 70 por
ciento del agua que se consume es de uso
agrícola un 25 por ciento es de uso
doméstico y solamente un 45 por ciento
de uso industrial entonces no se hizo
esa inversión y hoy está presentándose
un problema grave que se está atendiendo
con autotanques acá nos llamamos pipas
para garantizar el abasto en lo que
llueve que se espera que llueva a
principios de octubre pero no es una
solución inmediata es simplemente una
solución de emergencia no
claro juan carlos también le digo ante
todo este contexto que me está diciendo
además teniendo en cuenta que en
monterrey digamos es la capital
industrial de méxico era previsible
esta situación la responsabilidad que
tendría en este caso también el gobierno
federal y el gobierno local ante la
falta de agua en nuevo león
pues por supuesto que era para decir
pero que no sé no se hizo en la
inversión que se tenía que hacer de
construirse acueductos al canceló ese
proyecto hace como unos 8 años más o
menos es nueve años y este pues aquí
están las consecuencias
lo que es previsible es que no no habrá
sequía en los próximos años producto del
cambio climático y lo curioso es que el
sur de nuestro país las zonas más pobres
que tienen meses lame menos garantizado
digamos el abasto de agua potable y por
ello problemas gastrointestinales
hay 2 estados chiapas y trabajos que
concentran el 60 por ciento de toda la
aduana nacional y bueno pues a futuro
van a ser las únicas fuentes posibles de
agua otra opción son las desalinizadoras
pero pues para son muy caras no se ha
hecho una inversión importante en eso no
se ha previsto y requiere una inversión
bastante alta hay que considerar que son
se trata de más de 5 millones de
habitantes en la ciudad de monterrey
le quería preguntar también lo que
estaba precisamente hablando el cambio
climático que evidentemente va a agravar
esta situación de sequía y falta de agua
digamos los expertos y el gobierno
tendrían un plan de acción ante lo que
estamos viendo con la crisis climática
global
no no hay no hay el anuncio que acaba de
hacer el gobernador del nuevo león pues
ese que te decía que van a utilizar
carrotanques van a llevar más de 500
restos para lograr surtir a las colonias
a los ciudadanos pero no resuelven el
problema de fondo el problema de fondos
encontrar fuentes de abasto y no se ve a
corto y largo plazo una solución
propuesta desde ahora se piensa
construir una nueva presa que se llama
el cuchillo 2 actualmente hay tres
presas que se re la boca el
cuchillo te digo que dos de ellas están
completamente secas prácticamente
ya no dan para más
se empieza a construir una nueva presa
pero eso va a tardar tiempo y tomara
quizás algunos años y no necesariamente
puede garantizar el abasto en una ciudad
tan importante como monterrey 'juan
carlos i' y digamos temor dentro de la
población de monterrey que dicen los
ciudadanos además como lo retrata
retrata a la prensa nacional cuando
hacen los reportajes digamos en el nuevo
león ante la falta de este líquido vital
y por supuesto que de preocupación
porque como te decía la mayoría de los
hogares reciben el agua por presión no
tienen lo que llamamos cisternas es
decir mecanismos de almacenamiento en
los hogares y esto pues lo que ves en
pantalla es precisamente lo que está
sucediendo que la gente está llegando
con cubetas a recoger algo de agua para
hervirla para consumirla para utilizarla
y por supuesto que eso ha generado
incluso
protestas y hasta enfrentamientos entre
personas que no se equivocaban quienes
advertían hace ya bastante tiempo hace
unas dos décadas que la guerra futura
sin extradición de que vaya a haber
guerra pero que las guerras futuras iban
a ser por aguas no y ese es el problema
que están enfrentando precisamente en el
norte de méxico claro por el agua y
también por los alimentos pues juan
carlos se me acaba el tiempo para seguir
hablando
señor
sin nada más quiero agregar a una de las
principales industrias del país están
allá si la producción agrícola que
exporta a los estados unidos está para
allá así que el problema tiene secuelas
posteriores que pueden afectar la
productividad y el empleo no solamente
de abasto de agua sin duda alguna
también repercusión económica juan
carlos gracias entonces por su tiempo
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 buena mañana
gracias raúl un gusto